this is a Ghana's scaling multiplayer
game servers with open source I hope
you're in the right place if you're not
it's okay you can leave um I'm Mac
Mandal I'm gonna talk for a little bit
then I'll be joined on stage by Kelton
all from Ubisoft and then after that
Edward chin from super solid so if you
wanted to talk about open source and
multiplayer games and dedicated game
servers you should hopefully be in the
right place cool before we get started
that's about me but like who cares I'd
like to know a little bit more about all
of you so that we can sort of tailor
this a little bit hands up people here
who work on multiplayer games excellent
you are all in the right room awesome
people here who are familiar with like
Ducker or containers a lot of you
awesome people here are familiar with
kubernetes what do you not all of you
that's okay totally fine - awesome all
right so that's that's pretty good um
before we get stuck into things
Marketing gave me the slide this is good
no it is good actually I've been I've
been super proud of the work that Google
is doing this year across multiple
product areas we really have basically a
suite of products that work across the
games industry to help you connect hit
create connect and scale there we go
I've said the words we're good let's
move on all right so let's talk about
multiplayer games and all the good
things therein lie so I want to talk
about very specific types of multiplayer
games obviously multiplayer is a vast
and varied you know ecosystem of things
primarily what I want to talk about is
your fast-paced online multiplayer games
right your fortnight's your overwatch is
your rocket leagues that kind of stuff
we're gonna actually see a demo a little
later on there's an open source game
called stenotic it's a fast paced FPS
anyone here know cinetic people who know
synodic because they've seen my talks
before
yeah same group okay cool no it is
actually a really fun little game we're
gonna use that as a demo but is it is
very much that type of game um we're
gonna just set some basic foundational
stuff for people who aren't as familiar
with multiplayer games but for some of
you I'm guessing this will probably be
things that you're already somewhat
familiar with
so when running fast-paced online
multiplayer games usually and a fairly
prevalent way of doing this and there's
there's a variety of ways is doing it
through what we were commonly referred
to as a dedicated game server or an
authoritative server so essentially what
this means is you have a set of clients
say like four people playing a game and
they connect to some individual
simulation server that sits somewhere on
the Internet
it's you know controlling the physics of
the game what players are doing it's
essentially the authority of everything
that's happening inside the game when
usually players are sending in things
like hey I did this thing like I fired a
rocket or I'm moving forward or I'm
running now and it's the job of the
dedicated game server to do a lot of the
work to determine exactly what's
happening in send information back to
those players to let you know you know
yes you did hit this player or yes you
sort of go all that kind of stuff
there's a couple of good reasons for
this and this could be a total other
talk in and of itself the two big ones
being that one having a dedicated game
server gives you a bit more control over
what's going on and can give you some
avenues to stop cheating because people
are horrible and they like to hack stuff
um and the other thing is that
unfortunately we can't control the speed
of light would be really lies if we
could
so having control over the geographic
region of where you put your dedicated
game server means that you have some
control over how much lag there's gonna
be between players based on where they
are around the world right so if we want
to play a game and like we're all in San
Francisco we want to put our state game
server in San Francisco which is awesome
we probably don't want to put it in
Australia that would be bad because it's
very far away and then we get big lag
time so that gives us some control over
what is we want to do so how do we how
do we run these so traditionally how do
we do this this is probably fairly
familiar to a lot of people we might
have a couple of people who want to play
a game they usually connect to some kind
of matchmaker and the matchmakers job is
to group people by social graph and
skill level and all that kind of good
stuff and then usually they talk to some
kind of the spoke server manager thing
right where and it says cool like I know
about a whole
like vm's or something like that and I
need to go find like some CPU resources
and some memory resources and spin up
this game server for a person to play on
and find a port and do all that kind of
work and do it across potentially
thousands and thousands of machines and
then once I've got that game server up
and running I grab the IP and port or
ports that it's running on and I pass
that all the way back to the players so
that they can connect directly to the
game and we can now play again that's a
lot of work so the pot that argon is and
the things that we want to talk about
today is really like this pot how do we
do the orchestration of game servers how
do we like find the right amount of
resources to run our game servers on how
do we know that they're up and down how
do we make sure that we have lots of
them sitting there waiting to do stuff
like how do we do that whole process
that's kind of a very foundational task
that we all kind of need to do if we
want to run dedicated game servers and I
think is also kind of a solve problem
that lots of us have done over and over
again so having a single solution is
super nice so speaking of single
solutions um a few of us came together
and looked at this and said okay there
should be like a standard solution for
us doing this this shouldn't be
something that we all reinvent the wheel
over and over again it's a foundational
piece it's nothing actually that secret
sauce about how we do stuff for game
servers and run multiplayer games the
actual games themselves and the pieces
of the games that's the secret sauce so
came together built out a project um
Kyle's gonna talk a little bit about
that a little bit later between the the
collaboration between us and maybe soft
but basically yeah we wanted to build an
open-source platform for you to run host
and orchestrate your dedicated game
servers across large clusters and
machines so my job here today is kind of
to show you how some of that works and
give you some background on that and and
my follow up people will tell you a bit
more about the experience so first
things first some of you were familiar
with kubernetes for those of you who
aren't familiar with kubernetes
kubernetes in that their open source
project that originally got started by
google but has involvement from Red Hat
and a bunch of very very very large
companies and has been used a variety of
places including github and eat
and been running Pokemon go and you can
read a bunch of stuff it has become I
would like to say almost eight probably
a fairly standard defector way of
running large-scale distributed systems
across large numbers of machines if
you're not familiar at all just think of
it as a way to programmatically and
declaratively say I want this software
to run over lots and lots of machines
and at base level that's what it does
there's more nuance to it than that but
that's that's basically what it does and
we're able to leverage this it's runs
game servers so there's a few really
important things here that I think are
worth mentioning even if you're not that
familiar with kubernetes one kubernetes
it's an open source project
quite obviously I work at Google cloud
we have a manager version of kubernetes
quo gke but kubernetes itself is open
source and will run pretty much anywhere
you want to run it on us perfect you
want to run it on your machine fine you
want to run a single cluster inside your
QA workstations perfect you want to run
it across multiple clouds awesome right
so anywhere that your players are and
you want to be able to reach them you
can put a crit minetti's cluster which
is great right because sometimes players
end up in strange places around the
world and you need to run your
infrastructure there the other thing
that I really like about this is also
that it simplifies a lot of your systems
so I say this because cribben adizs is
great for running your like micro
services and that kind of stuff your
market places and you're all and that's
awesome but usually what I see when I
talk to game studios and development
shops is they have one system for all
their back-end services and then one
completely different system for all
their like dedicated game servers my
perspective here is if you can run the
same platform for both suddenly you can
run the same tools you can use the same
infrastructure you can use a lot of the
same ecosystem tooling that you use
across the board and so suddenly you're
like okay I don't need to relearn a
whole new system to do this these sort
of things that are usually fairly
interlinked finally if you're not
familiar with kubernetes like that is an
ecosystem that has ridiculously blown up
over the last three or four years I can
literally say that when we built it on
as we were standing on the shoulders of
giants because there are so many people
working on this project and so many
people working on projects around this
project then it labels us to leverage a
whole bunch of stuff so anyway enough
preaching let
me show you basically how this stuff
works so potentially unsurprisingly the
first building block of everything is we
put stuff in containers this means that
if you want to run a game server we
really aren't restricting you about how
you do it as long as you can put things
in container you're pretty much good to
go so as long as you can put stuff in a
druckmann container is great
we do have an integrated SDK so there's
an integration point with your game
server itself we have some pre-built
SDKs that are gr PC based which is just
a way we do our PC calls but if you
don't like it you can always use rest so
it's fine basically the short answer is
if you want or integrate with your
engine we can find a way it's fine it's
all good there's lots a couple there's
there's lots of ways we can make that
work and this is really just so that we
can see what your game server is doing
is it healthy has it started yet
is it ready to take players the game
server can access its configuration for
gun as all the good things that it needs
to be able to do okay so let's actually
look at like how we get game servers
running on this so Cooper Nettie's
itself like I said is declarative
basically we tell it to do something and
we trust that the system does it and one
of the lovely things about kubernetes is
it and also enables us to extend it so
by default kubernetes comes with a bunch
of stuff that works great for web
servers right fire me up ten of these
and make sure they stay up and also put
a load balancer in front of it that's
great that doesn't work necessarily for
game servers so when you install it on
is suddenly it has this new verb inside
this configuration yamo files that we
set up whole game server and now it
understands how game servers work so
here as I said we have a game server
we're able to give it a name or we can
actually have criminales create the name
there's also good stuff here we can
specify a port policy so cuber Nettie's
itself doesn't do dynamic ports
organized we'll do that for you so it'll
do the routing for the ports for your
game servers as they come through
without you having to worry about doing
any of that work and then you can
basically specify a set of containers or
just a single container for a game
server that runs your example here we're
running so notic it's a simple template
that we have here if you are familiar
with kubernetes this is actually down
here a full pod spec so if you want to
do volume amounts or config maps or
multiple containers or anything like
that you totally can that's all
so this is cool for sake of time I'm not
gonna show a demo of this this is just
running an individual game server
basically you can spin it up and spin it
down that's cool but what we really want
and I think for a lot of game server
workloads is what we actually want is
Lodge groups of game servers so
sometimes game servers take a little
while to spin up sometimes they're slow
it's okay so if you had a set of 100's a
like 10,000 or 50,000 game servers or
less which is fine to just sitting there
waiting for players to come in then we
can manage that here with what we call
fleets so if you're familiar with
kubernetes rather than having like pods
and deployments we have game servers and
fleets so a fleet is basically a
specification of game servers but we
just say how many of them we want so
here we're saying we just want to like
we don't have that many players yet we
just have two people it's fine and down
here we specify what our game server
specification looks like it's just an
extension from that nothing nothing too
crazy so now we can have big fleets of
game servers that's just super cool we
can scale them up as much as we need but
we need a way to atomically access a
game server within that fleet all right
so we need to be able to say hey I have
a player like say it's come from a
matchmaker or something similar I need
to be able to be like that whole big
group there please just give me one and
give me one in a way that makes sense
for a variety of reasons so we have this
concept of what we call allocations and
allocations are actually kind of special
and they're kind of Awesome um
allocations are primarily I think you'll
find you usually do this through an API
call everything I've shown you here is
through llamó files which is the
declarative nature everything I do here
I could also do through an API call to
the Gruben a DS API I don't have to do
it this way this is just easy to show
for demonstrative purposes but I'm able
to do an allocation with this so if I
wanted to say I want out of the Sonata
gleet I'm gonna send it an allocation
I'm gonna do here I'm actually I have a
variety of things I can do with
allocations but here I'm just saying out
of the fleet sinaitic please give me a
game server and said it's a
and allocated a special right allocated
is that special status that says players
are playing on this game please do not
delete them because players get mad if
you you know just decide to delete games
for some reason and they post stuff on
reddit and it's just no fun no one likes
that and this is probably one of like
the core things that makes Agana
iguana's is that it understands that
transition of state between hey I have a
game server no one's playing on it who
cares if it dies - hey I have a game
server players are playing on this this
is now like really important and like
please do not remove this in any way
shape or form so allocation is the thing
that allows us to do that and we can
actually do a whole bunch of things with
game server allocation we can do
preferred sets we can do like multiple
requirements there's there's lots of
good stuff here but essentially we're
just doing some some label matching here
where and we can have arbitrary key
value pairs in one month so want to do a
bit of an extended demo and show you it
in action and make it a little less
abstract so hopefully nothing goes wrong
awesome so I have a crouppen a nice
cluster
it has about 20 nodes on it give or take
this is the command-line tooling so it's
all set up I don't have a gun is
installed so let's actually install
iguana's we're gonna use a package
manager called how to install a ghana's
and I'm gonna install it and it'll be a
gonna so I'm gonna install that the
production version of that the most
recent release and that's pretty much
there that's pretty much what I have to
do to install it there's a few different
ways we can do it we want to have a look
there's a few components that installs a
few different things there here we have
the the controller system as well as
some some latency measurement stuff that
we have installed but that's all that's
all good that's pretty much what I had
to do to install so if I want to create
a fleet we can use the same Yama file we
did previously
again we could do this through an API we
could use a bunch of different
so example stenotic fleet diamo and we
can enter that here so this is this is
quite cool so we installed it on is and
that installed those extensions we were
talking about previously so now we can
actually say things like hey kubernetes
show me the game servers that are in
your system and show me the details
about them that's something that
kubernetes didn't know about before but
now it's integrated directly in our
tools they're spinning up on I think
some new clusters oh come up in a minute
of course it's a demo so something's
yeah there's they're just pulling down
that figures they'll come up in a minute
but we can see things here so we can see
like what address and what port they're
on they're currently scheduled they'll
kick over to ready in probably about a
minute once everything's happy and we
can we can kind of mess around with this
now and see it in a variety of ways if
we want to have a look at it as a fleet
for example right we can see here that
there's true currently desired and
they'll soon be ready there are the
Sonata Kimmage is like a gig and a half
and so it takes a little bit sometimes
to pull down to it to machine but it'll
be there in a minute and we can see some
various things on here so if we want to
scale this we can do so so let's just
scale the fleet it keeps you all fleet
I'm typing down here so it's always fun
a fleet oh no I know I did it wrong
sorry scale there we go yeah we get the
close of completion it's not Inc
replicas I'll say 200 all right so
that'll that'll start coming up so now
if we say get fleet right how good the
two finally came up I'll come up pretty
quick but we can see that that's gonna
that's gonna start to grow if we want to
have some fun yeah that should be green
now cuz we've actually got that that's
we can start actually seeing dashboards
for is that gonna work for me what did
that crash
of course demos right can trust them
there we go awesome so that's not
working we have pre-built gravano
dashboards and hooks into a Prometheus
so we use a library called our consensus
for doing our statistics and metrics so
you can use either Prometheus or stretch
driver if you want or pretty much
anything that open census will support
so if we want to have a look here and
have a look at our number of game
servers for example that is tiny and you
can't see anything
but you'll start to see the number of
game servers start to grow this is
usually running a little bit slower than
what actually is happening and we can
start to see things like how fast our
game servers are coming up we can start
to see rates of what state they're in
what fleet's numbers they have how
they're distributed across our cluster
there's a variety of different types of
statistics that we're able to take
advantage of which is really really nice
they're starting to come up now every go
about a hundred or so that's pretty nice
so we can do all sorts of fun things
here as well so if we have a look at our
fleet there we go we had 106 ready
that's that's much better
they're coming out pretty quick so let's
let's actually do an allocation and
we'll play with that so notic game
server allocation so again you would
probably do this through a cube
kubernetes api call but we're gonna do
this through this just for demonstrative
purposes and I'm gonna tell it that - oh
yeah mol basically says the result that
you're gonna send back to me that
usually would be Jason just put it out
as yeah Mel on screen so we can see what
it's doing so we can run that and that's
going to basically give us back an
allocation and the bit that we care
about is really this year so it's gonna
take one of those game servers out of
that set look through model will
basically look at how many we have
available and grab the one that is ready
and sitting there waiting to be played
on so and give us back the address so we
can see here that that's on three five
two three six one two two that's the
game server name that we had previously
and there it is state is allocated so
let's play game open on the right window
yes
so I'm just gonna move that over a
little perfect let's see if I can type
this correctly over my shoulder yep I
count one two two one six nine one seven
three five three let us see how the
internet is here that is actually good
that my mouse has disappeared ah here we
go
yep alright so I'm just gonna play that
in the corner so this is me put that on
this is me trying to place a notic oh I
see so actually he still has this
hitting's where I dropped all the
weaponry so I could take screenshots but
that's all right
but this is me playing stenotic on Agana
is running on a cluster in the cloud
basically this is running on a GK
cluster on uswest
we have some BOTS running around I am
terrible clearly because apparently I'm
underwater for no apparent reason she's
fine
where am I and also trying to play on a
track that I'm blaming I blame it on the
trackpad mostly there we go
thank you I'll let someone kill me
that's where some of those
there we go so we have a few people
coming and playing playing against me
but yeah this is running up on
kubernetes I'm still working really
really well and we were able to play a
game which is super nice I'll show you
some other fun things while we're here
so you can start to see some more fun
things in the graphics now that it take
a little bit of time but like we have
199 already sitting there you see up in
the top left-hand corner that's all
green now we can start seeing some more
things here about our rate of stuff
coming up as well as how many are ready
we also have auto scaling capabilities
which I'm not going to talk too much
about today we have grass to that all
that sort of metrics all the stuff that
you kind of just need to have to run
game servers I make that really
important stuff without like you having
to do the work to write all this
plumbing type of code so there's a lot
of really cool stuff inside of garnet so
hopefully that gives you a bit of an
idea of how that whole system works we
come over here into we can also have
some more fun because we have some time
I can scale this back down so if I say
scale fleet synodic replicas say I want
to make that zero um that's gonna start
deleting game servers
but we have one game server that's
allocated and so we don't want that one
to die and so we will actually see is
yes it will go and get rid of all the
game servers that we would have
previously but it won't touch that one
game server where we have players on it
so that's super important so even if we
are editing our fleets and we have like
a rolling update rolling through which
is something we support or you want to
scale a fleet to adjust workloads based
on say maybe you have less players
coming in you always know that your
players are safe on that same server see
how quickly that comes down there we go
and so we have that one allocated now
like that never that never went away
I'd always stays there that's super
important cool so that was me showing
you how some of that stuff worked that
means now that when you have players
that want to play a game rather than
connecting to some bespoke system they
can take some sort of custom matchmaker
potentially open match for some strange
reason also a fun project we work on but
they can talk directly to the kubernetes
api they can reuse all the stuff that
kubernetes
gives you right as soon as we install is
gonna is right the tooling changes the
API changes it understands how to manage
all these things and in the grouping
Eddie's API I can be like hey Akana is
right like I'd really like a game server
to be allocated to me please so Cheers
thanks I appreciate that and then the
information can be sent back to the
players and the players can play a game
and so you really can just focus on what
that game server is doing and how it
works rather than having to worry about
how it spins up and spins down all right
enough of me I'd like to introduce
called Elim to come talk about how
things are going over to be soft hi for
some reason that mark and hive sinner
t-shirts Sam Karl I'm director of
development at Ubisoft I'm responsible
for the multiplayer products particular
services in the online group so that's
mainly D Network code matchmaking
as well as the server allocation
products so I work it to be soft I'd say
you probably know you be stuff for third
largest publishers we have a bunch of
people 14,000 employees and that's
that's growing so it's a pretty big
pretty big companies are you probably
know our games and so today I want to
talk a bit about why we actually were
interested to collaborate on an agonist
and let me start by talking a bit about
the change that's happening in the
industry today thank you if we look back
it's not that long ago
releasing the game used to be the
objective and now it's just only the
beginning like players expecting to see
their games as a service it's not just
the Bucks product anymore
you want to see a service they want to
see a game that keeps changing all the
time you want to be surprised by new
content whenever the log on on to the up
to the game so that game as a service
trend it's something that continues and
access
and I think that when you look at cloud
gaming for example to me it's just an
extension natural extension of this
that's the way that players wants to
have their game let me talk a little bit
about what the impact it has on our
games so when we look at the game
actually have the game client so what's
the game client well is it thick client
it can be pretty big like when we look
at the latest SSS screed let's say 42
gigs client so that's that's pretty big
that client is going to connect to an
ecosystem of services that will be
running so that includes stuff like
matchmaking challenges stats whatever
and as we are building rich games as
services it means that that ecosystem of
services is becoming a richer and richer
because that's one good place where we
can deliver value and content to our
players one thing that we see as well is
if we're going to build that type of
games means that we need to have content
that will be available for the players
for a long time ok so an easy way to
make a game that will have like hundreds
of hours of gameplay is to make it a
multiplayer game so that's the reason
why we see a lot of multiplayer games
nowadays we see and so typically it
means that you're going to need to have
the game a game server to actually host
that multiplayer application now that's
going to come with the number of
challenges first we need to be agile we
need to be able to adapt super fast to
the needs of the players and that's true
across the entire ecosystem like we know
how to be fast to deploy new services
[Music]
but we also need to be able to do it
through the game client and the game
servers as well to be able to deploy new
new content another challenge that we
have as well as the question of scale
and the question of proximity we want to
make sure that these game servers
sit very close to the players because if
a latency is high that's going to have
an impact on the performance that we
daddy see when you think about scale
game servers or pretty CPU intensive to
give an idea at Ubisoft we currently
peak at the about a hundred thousand
virtual machines to run our game servers
when look at that like having a hundred
thousand virtual machines across like
dozens of data centers that's a pretty
big number that's going to be close to
the capacity of many data centers that
you that you see so that makes your
typical blue grid Bluegreen the
deployment quite of a quite a bit
challenge and so in that context making
that type of game is becoming
increasingly complex and I think that
collaboration is something that is
important it's nice slide a it's a bit
cheesy I think that we could make a nice
poster you know like you have getting
these nice motivation posters but
seriously collaboration between our
teams at Ubisoft community
collaborations between the brands and
collaborations with other people in the
industry are outside of industry I think
it's something that's very important and
that's basically how agonized was born
so a while back it's about like maybe a
bit more than a year ago I
we knew that studio was coming and I was
talking to mark and for some reason like
if we look at stadia and we have the
games client running on GCP it makes
sense to have the server running into
city as well so I was talking to mark
and says hey what are goals planned
regarding game servers and we chatted
for a little while and we realized that
we had a very nice collaboration
opportunity or basically we'd say well
let's put together the knowledge of
Google for what it means to be able to
scale and deploy containers a scale with
supersoft expertise of what it takes to
actually build and manage game servers
and that's basically how Hagin des was
born so it's not mint sauce project
makes it possible to deploy game servers
at scale across community so it was a
nice nice collaboration on so one thing
that I really like is since agonize is
based on communities what do we get
well we actually had a lot of
flexibility because now we can actually
deploy these game servers across
different type of clusters so we can go
for example to we can deploy them with
physical clusters and that's a good way
to save the cost that's important and
when we have a spike then we can
actually go on the cloud to handle the
two EDB to be able to handle the bursts
so organize is something that's part of
a wider ecosystem but Ubisoft
we have it's it's part of it completely
co system made up of hundreds of
applications and micro services to
manage the online at Ubisoft and I think
it was a pretty good example of
collaboration between two companies
thanks
[Applause]
hello hi I'm Edie I'm one of the
co-founders at supersolid
apologized for not being on brand today
with the gunner's t-shirt but maybe
later yeah so in the next five to ten
minutes I'm going to tell you a bit
about one of the games that we have in
development I'm gonna go through why we
decided to use a gun is how we're using
it and also a bit about our experience
with it so far so quickly first a bit of
background
supersolid we're a team of about 40
people we're based in London in the UK
and so far we had these five games so
our first two games super penguins and
Pororo penguin run are both infinite
runners we've got adventure town which
is a town building light RPG game and
then our two most recent games are food
streets and home Street there are
resource management simulation games as
you probably noticed none of these are
our multiplayer games or at least not
real-time synchronous multiplayer games
but that is what we currently have in
development I can show you a bit more
about this game it's called snake rivals
and here is a short teaser which I might
need what to play me
[Music]
[Applause]
great thanks for that much so thanks
that's so that's our latest game it's
out later this year it's called snake
rifles it's our first real time
synchronous multiplayer game the idea is
that there are 50 players all in an
arena at once and we've got these three
different modes there's a classic mode
which is kind of similar to an i/o game
if you like so players come in and the
session ends when they die and then
we've got two other modes Gold Rush mode
and a battle royale mode in Gold Rush
it's more timed so you're in more
strategic gameplay you're trying to make
kills or steal kills and at the end the
player who has the most points wins and
the third mode Balamory Ally I'm
assuming that everyone knows what that
is
and basically the last surviving player
wins
so about I guess 12 months ago a little
less than that we decided to make this
game the first question I guess was well
how are we gonna build it and quite
quickly we decided to use kubernetes so
the big question for early research was
what implementation of communities we
wanted to use we settled on gke which is
Google's implementation of kubernetes we
did that for a few reasons
I think we we basically we tried it out
on a few different services with gke we
found it was just the easiest to set up
and get running
there were also kind of a few other
advantages that we liked the ease of
using the GCP services such as low
balancing as well that was that was
pretty important to us debugging live
code easy error tracking of live
incidents and also we found it's it's
also relatively cost effective which is
also something important to consider so
having decided to use gke we found that
we also had three key requirements this
is stuff that I guess mark went through
earlier but is it's pretty important for
multiplayer games so the first thing is
that we've got to be able to start up
game servers on demand so in the endless
mode for example when the arena fills up
with 50 players we need to start a new
arena so we need to be able to start
some your game server and for the other
modes when players want to start a new
game again we need to start up game so I
was in demand and when the games are
over when they're finished we also need
to be able to shut them down the second
requirement which I think mark touched
on as well is to be able to protect
running servers from shutting down so
this is is pretty key so if you know a
service gets outdated for example you
don't want your your game servers to
shut down because you know everyone or
all your players currently playing will
get kicked off their game and then you
know your Google Play rating goes down
and that's that's always a terrible
thing then the third requirement is of
course the scale based on demand so a
number of players and their location as
well and well what we found was
eagerness just helps solve all of these
issues for us and that's that's the main
reason why we decided to use a bonus
moving on to exactly how we're using a
gun is so this is kind of what's going
on with snake rifles so when you start a
game
I guess the client asks for the game
mode so whatever game mode the player
asks for that then goes to the Google
blow the Google global load balancer the
easiest thing to say and that asks for
the matchmaker also selects the best
cluster for the client to to connect to
the matchmaker then finds that specific
game mode again for that to join and
kubernetes via REST API gets the list of
game servers and that's managed by
Gunners which maintains the pool of game
servers the matchmaker then decide
from the list of game servers and again
by REST API with the Gunners we mark
that selected game service allocated so
that you know importantly it doesn't get
destroyed the matchmaker then returns
that one game server to the client and
the game starts and you know the player
obviously has a great time playing the
game and when that game finishes again
virus API and gona's we then mark that
server as shutting down and that's
that's at a at a pretty high level how
we're using GAE in a gona's and so
finally I guess it's a question on how
we're finding it and yeah it's it's been
pretty great so far we've seen that it's
you know it's a pretty supportive
environment so there's a slack group
that's pretty responsive there's a
Google group there are community
meetings that happen quite regularly it
allows us to influence a roadmap of
what's being produced prioritization of
that as well and then obviously we were
able to report any bugs that that we
come across so that's been great we've
also through this I guess built a great
relationship with Google that's given us
great access to training materials so
courses and kubernetes workshops as well
which has been really positively
received by our developers so thanks
thanks for that we've also had access to
a production readiness review and that's
been really useful so they assess the
game architecture and they give they
give suggestions I guess on how to
operate that at Google standards that
see the sre methodology and all of this
is it's just super important to us
because you know I think all game
developers here just know how how hard
it is to develop a hit game and once you
had that you just want to make sure that
you know
things scales properly and all your game
servers are up and running I guess
finally you know you probably have to
say something negative if there is
anything negative at all I you know the
only thing is to point out it's it's you
know an alpha service so you might get
what you expect from alpha services
you know the feature gets deprecated you
might have to you know code around that
or you might be working away at a
feature and then you realize that
actually you know that that's what
they're building next but you know what
like it it really doesn't matter to us
the communication has been great so we
avoided a lot of these issues and also
you know if we weren't using it we'd
really have to build it ourselves anyway
so for us it's it's really a has been a
no brainer so to sum up
yup so with you know with GCP with GAE
ago Nez it's really been able to allowed
us to be able to to build snake rivals
with a relatively small team probably
probably just you know to two server
developers in under 12 months so that's
been great thanks and and look out for
snake rebels coming later this year
Thanks
[Applause]
thank you so much ed and Carl for
joining us one make sure we have plenty
of time for questions as well but some
things things to talk about as well so
we wrap up with there's some things I
want to mention so I gave you all the
brief overview with iguanas you haven't
looked at in a while it's definitely
increasing at a fairly rapid rate which
is really great but there's a lot of
other features that we didn't get to
touch on today including I have the fact
that it works across cloud providers
right we work against vanilla kubernetes
that's very important to us
we want to make sure it works everywhere
we didn't talk about auto scaling but
that is something that is ingrained and
inbuilt so we have fleet auto scaling we
work directly with the standard
kubernetes autoscaler as well so dues
clusters cluster or the my god cluster
auto scaling hello GDC so that's all
available as well we have a suite of
local developer tools so for example if
you don't want to run a full crew Benes
cluster on your machine you just want to
do some light testing we can do some sdk
local tooling things like that so make
that a little bit easier for you to do
and I showed you some of the metrics and
dashboards but there's a whole suite of
more metrics and dashboards that you can
use and that's an ever-growing thing
that we want to keep expanding on
because it's the it's the second day and
the third day things that really get you
right it's the stuff that making sure
you know exactly what's happening in
your system on the launch day and then
the day after that and after that that
really kind of gets you as you go
through on the roadmap coming forward we
I would actually say I just want to be
very clear as well like on the roadmap
we are very directed by our community if
you're here now and your interest in the
project I would definitely love to say
like come in try it out provide feedback
there are a lot of features that are
getting developed right now that maybe a
month ago we wouldn't have even looked
at but because the community got
involved we started to look at it and be
like oh this is the thing that's really
important like a lot of us have shifted
gears change priorities we worked with
other people who are using the tooling
to really build the things they need so
that's definitely a big thing things
things highlighted we've done a bunch of
performance improvements in the last few
months that have been great but we're
looking to do some more that are coming
up again like I said more metric
collection to display ops is hugely
important we've got some commercial
engine integrations right now
you want to run like you need to you're
unreal you kind of have to hook into our
REST API it's not the cleanest but we
want to have some stuff out of the box
you can still do it it's fine we want to
make that a smoother experience Multi
cluster multi cluster is also a front of
mind right now it's fairly focused on
like individual clusters we have some
design tickets around right now for
doing a multi cluster allocation and
it's some other things around that that
we're looking at potentially working
with some of the signal tea cluster
things there's a lot of work going on
the multi cluster space for kubernetes
so there's plenty of space there to room
it with to grow Windows hosting is
something I also get asked about a lot
generally speaking we are leaning on the
work of the proven Eddie's community so
if anyone's here from Microsoft please
keep doing the good work you're doing
with Windows thank you we appreciate
that as soon as that stuff bubbles up
into the kubernetes ecosystem then we
were able to do that we realize that's
important both from a development
perspective because a lot of us work on
Windows and we just want that short
iteration time but also there are people
who run production workloads on Windows
and that's totally cool as well so we
want to do that definitely a lot lost if
you're interested in a gun is we
actually release this just the other day
so if you want a very quick way of
getting an iguana's cluster up and
running for test purposes you can
actually go to the Google cloud
marketplace you'll see there's some
documentation there and you can go
search for gun s go through and it'll
create a cluster for you you can
actually do the installation right there
it's basically a 1:1 click install I
would say it's generally used for
testing purposes we have some hardening
rules that we do in production that we
couldn't quite do yet in the marketplace
but we'll get to at some point but if
you just want to be like hey how does
this thing work how can I use it let me
try it out this is a great place to
start and get your feet wet lastly I
will say very quickly before we get to
questions we've got plenty of time for
questions which is great my business
cards are up here at the front along
with a whole bunch of a gonnae stickers
if people like stickers I hear
developers like stickers my business
cards are here so please feel free to
come up and grab one if you haven't got
questions right now but you think you
might I say a week from now two weeks
from now a month from now please grab my
details come join us on slack come get
involved on github we'd love to have you
but if you want to learn more of the
website is up there at Agony's dev
please follow the iguana's twitter on
advantage twitter if you want to
learn more about kubernetes Crippen at
his i/o and google container engine
before we wrap up and open the floor for
questions thank you all for coming in
and joining hopefully enjoying yourself
with us I know your time is valuable so
I appreciate you all coming and spending
your time here so without further ado if
anyone has any questions I would love to
hear them if you want to pop on stage to
all do that two questions
so the question was does the Duggar
container set any hard limits
not really no as your docker containers
get larger they can be unwieldly there
are some strategies we do have that
we're starting to talk about internally
about how to share assets between
containers and how to love them up
quickly we can do some in memory mapping
type things that's another area we want
to explore as we go forward to a lot of
people in development just build really
big containers like three gig four gig
containers and it's fine they just
transfer the network a little bit slower
you got another question I know oh there
we go perfect it's much about allocation
that you showed yep you talked a little
bit about that okay so there yeah
question about how we do port allocation
basically the way we have it set up is
for each game server it's it's
essentially within a certain network
namespace so what we do is the container
starts up and it's whatever port that
you tell it that it's gonna start up on
so the whole they all start up
internally the same and we set up
kubernetes we set up a crib entities
Chris port basically which what it does
is it'll set up a I P tables route that
runs through through the node and then
directly into the container we found
through testing it's like worst case
scenario and even doesn't hit that very
often about half a millisecond what it
means then you can still run sidecar
containers you still run other services
alongside it and know that that is that
is contained within their network
namespace so you can do some really nice
stuff that way and it was it was a nice
trade-off that way I think there was you
who had you got a question next sorry I
just think I just missed the what your
is that the free to download or do I
need to buy the trial Oh for the
marketplace oh that's a good question
like how do I work it on the marketplace
ooh if you want to install it on Google
container engine we have a $300 free
trial that is valid for up to 12 months
so you can you can go use that if you
want to do it locally you can do it
locally if you want to use there's a
couple of local kubernetes tools kind K
IND or mini cube so you can install
either those locally and then the stolid
gonna is on that and that's not gonna
cost you anything
I wasn't thinking you know trying to
testing in a multiplayer game for my own
game for just no future yeah so you
could do either of those you can test it
locally on your machine or run it run a
trial account on Google
I'm also thinking about it as you know
I'm I'm attending a school at the
academic university and then it's just
testing the different computer that hey
can you hit me or something in that boom
that's affect you or something that
that's why I was a planing for you know
okay there was I'm staring this way I
need to turn that way next high so it
seems like a lot of the kind of
architecture we just talked about is
useful in an example where you spin up a
pod you allocate the players and it
tears down in a traditional multiplayer
setting but how does this kind of work
where you might need to enter pod
communication in something like an MMO
where instances are just constantly
being spin up and for different players
and different zones and that sort of
thing that is my question so how does
this work in a macosx so we have been
relatively focused on more of a
session-based thing I definitely want to
explore or I think we definitely want to
explore I should say we definitely want
to explore how we can support more MMO
type stuff the nice thing about
kubernetes is the way it's set up with
its networking model from foundation is
that all pods can talk to each other so
all pods as long as you have the IP
address of the pod you know you can
actually communicate within the
networking system within the cluster so
that sort of stuff is available to you
but I actually do want to explore more
if there are things that we can do at
more of that foundational sort of
orchestration layer of like how can we
eat I know exactly what that looks like
but how can we do like I don't know help
you with like geographic splitting or
that kind stuff that being said there's
nothing that necessarily stops you from
doing that like you can leave these up
for as long as you like if you want they
don't necessarily have to come down in
three minutes or twenty minutes or an
hour like as long as you want to do a
little bit of extra work over the top
you can still use them if you're doing
MMO type stuff there's there's nothing
inherently there that stops you from
doing that okay so I have one more umm
so you talked a little bit about hosting
on Windows oh yeah I was just curious
about how much exploration you've done
in terms of like nodes that are windows
and cue Bernays clusters but then more
importantly windows containers
yep specifically because we work on the
tools for playstation development guys
where most of it happen
I have not explored that really at all
there is a lot of work that is happening
we've
running Windows containers inside
kubernetes I'm not an expert on that
area okay there's a whole sink for it
there's no special interest group for
windows and containers as far as I
understand it it is coming they're
working on it
it was required there was some
requirement for some early release type
stuff on Windows to get the windows
container support needed for kubernetes
are coming through but it is coming it's
just a question of when it gets done is
the answer just go talk to Microsoft
guys sorry is the answer just go talk to
the Microsoft guys go join good there's
a cig windows group Oh incriminate so
communities the way the the actual open
source project destructors may have
special interest groups for different
areas so you can go on slacking on the
mailing lists they have regular meetings
so basically you can go see what the
what the structure is there and
everything is like available you can
it's all open ok awesome thank you yeah
it was over here I've been facing on the
other side how does this fit in with
Stadium how does this fit in with stadia
actually that's longer than I thought it
would to ask the the short answer here I
think is stays like I'm not gonna talk
on behalf of Stadium because it's not
the product area but the short answer
here is we talk they talk we talk a bit
about our network essentially and so if
there are instances which you are using
stadia and you want to have a dedicated
game server running it inside Google's
Network is ideal because we don't have
to go outside we were inside our own
network our product manager was talking
about this earlier this morning there's
a lot of inherent speed and cost savings
you can do there so there are some
instances where you may want to run a
dedicated game server but yeah that's
just we allow you to do that and so
awesome that's the short answer I
figured I get that question like first
in a couple of minutes
you mentioned getting some of the
metrics out of Agony's but what I'm kind
of more curious about is managing the
complexity of kubernetes are there any
good tools for like pulling out you know
it stack traces of server crashes or
things like that that you know presently
so generally speaking as long as
anything goes any any text goes actually
here's an interest question how do you
dump your server how do you jump your
server traces now is that just straight
- like a text file is it commits a log
so you don't like doing like heap dumps
yeah as long as any log speaking of let
me know let me try the stems again
speaking for Google crew Nettie's
engines and generally speaking on
communities as a whole if you spit your
logs out to foreground right so
basically to stand it out then they get
aggregated in central central logging
service if you're running on google
kubernetes engine it's already set up so
that our google container engine right
over the old name it's already set up so
that all the logs that go to foreground
go to stack driver they're searchable
you can output stuff so that's all
available to you just a standard log
aggregation and like I said in the top
right standing on the shoulders of
giants like that stuff we didn't have to
do it's just great like it's just there
it's awesome
I mean organize itself we actually spit
out Jason Jason logs so we do structured
logging and that goes straight in this
directory but it's like oh it's Jason
awesome and now it's like searchable and
it's fantastic so I'm super happy it's
not work we have to do thank you one
minute and 22 seconds no pressure
going once going twice awesome well
again thank you so much for hanging out
stickers and business guys are here
hopefully and if you want to chat more
will be around at GDC so thank you so
much
[Applause]